A aula de hoje é sobre as
partes da alma.
Eu quero começar com
2 passagens retiradas da
tradição literária antiga grega
e 2 da cultura de massa contemporânea
que revelam a extensão que faz
parte do entendimento
comum da natureza humana à
qual muitas vezes
estamos em conflito dentro
de nós mesmos.
Portanto, em A República, livro que
destacamos alguns trechos,
o Sócrates de Platão conta a
história de um homem que é tentado
a agir contra o seu melhor julgamento.
É a história de
Leôncio, e segue assim:
"Leôncio, filho de Aglaion,
voltando um dia do Pireu,
ladeava a parte exterior da
muralha da cidade
quando viu cadáveres
estendidos perto do carrasco.
Ele sentia – diz Sócrates, usando a
terminologia de Platão –
um apetite de olhar para eles.
Mas, ao mesmo tempo, sentiu
repugnância e se afastou.
Durante alguns instantes, ele lutou
contra si mesmo e tapou o rosto.
Mas, finalmente, dominado pelo
apetite, abriu os olhos bem abertos
e correndo para os cadáveres bradou:
'Olhem para vocês, seus desgraçados!
Fartem-se deste belo espetáculo.'"
Na aula de hoje, vamos falar mais
sobre a imagem peculiar
que Platão tem em mente quando
fala da alma tripartida,
envolvendo essa força que
ele chama de apetite.
Mas a descrição básica
realizada aqui não se encaixa
de nenhuma maneira num
determinado quadro platônico.
A ideia de que é
possível, por um lado,
se sentir compelido a fazer alguma coisa
– comer um pedaço de bolo de
chocolate, checar a página
do Facebook de alguém...
essas são tentações
que se pode tentar
controlar e lutar contra.
E a narrativa que será exposta
nas próximas 4 ou 5 aulas
é sobre os tipos de
estratégias disponíveis,
uma vez que esses tipos de conflitos
surgem de forma inevitável.
Então, esse é o nosso 1º
exemplo de um tipo de conflito
da tradição antiga;
um conflito entre o impulso do apetite
e o impulso de um certo tipo
de autorregulação.
O 2º exemplo vem da
Metamorfoses de Ovídio.
Uma longa história em que, na
passagem que vamos ler,
a personagem Medeia se vê
apaixonada contra a sua vontade
por um jovem chamado Jasão.
E aqui estou eu com uma
tradução do século 17
em rimas com dísticos.
"Enquanto isso Medeia, tomada
pelo desejo veemente,
Em razão se esforça para
apagar o fogo ardente;
Mas se esforça em vão!
Algum Deus (ela diz) é não,
e contrapõe perplexo o
conselho da razão."
Então aqui está Medeia,
tomada pelo desejo,
tentando se controlar por meio da
razão, dizendo a si mesma:
é um absurdo estar
apaixonada por este jovem,
é uma violação das
minhas obrigações.
Mas o seu esforço é em vão.
Ela tem a sensação de ter sido
superada por uma força externa
e o que a razão diz para ela fazer
é passar por cima disso.
E continua – esta é uma versão
rimada da passagem em prosa
do texto de Jonathan Haidt que
lemos para hoje –,
agora na voz de Medeia.
"Mas o amor, o amor irresistível, a
minha alma invade Discrição esta,
afeto que persuade.
Eu vejo o certo, e eu o aprovo também,
Condenam o errado – e o
errado ainda vem."
Portanto, essa sensação de ver o que é
certo, endossar o que é certo,
condenar o que é errado e,
mesmo assim, todavia,
encontrar-se fazendo o que vai contra
o julgamento do que é melhor
é um tropo fundamental na
tradição literária ocidental.
É um tropo fundamental na
tradição filosófica oriental.
E é um sentimento extraordinariamente
familiar na vida de todo mundo.
O 3º exemplo do tipo de tensão
que irrompe nesta conversa
sobre as partes da alma vem da internet.
Eis um artigo sobre a
decisão do Sweet 16
do ano passado.
Aqui está a manchete: "Conflito
entre emoção e análise
ao escolher os vencedores do Sweet 16".
"A maioria de vocês – diz a
publicação – envolvida com a NCAA
teve dificuldades na semana
passada para decidir
se os seus corações estavam
tentando induzi-los ao erro.
É difícil – afirma, ecoando
Medeia, ecoando Platão,
retirar a emoção (agora nas
próprias palavras do jornal) –,
no que muitos consideram ser a melhor
pós-temporada do esporte."
E ele continua descrevendo o
quão difícil é
assumir o mandato da razão
e escolher um time em que não
clamem as conexões emocionais.
Mas não encontramos isso apenas
no contexto esportivo.
Aqui está o 4º exemplo da
espécie de conflito da alma
a que se refere Platão.
Este vem do grande árbitro da
cultura de massa, Oprah.
"Preste atenção – diz a
Oprah, no seu site –,
porque estar no seu coração é
melhor do que no seu talão."
Nesse sentido, aqueles que leram
os textos sabem que...
se tivéssemos clickers, a Oprah
concorda com Platão ou com Hume?
Ela concorda com Platão...
mão esquerda...
Platão ou Hume?
Excelente.
Bom.
A ideia de Platão é que a
razão está no comando.
A sugestão de Hume na
passagem que lemos é que:
a razão é e deve ser a
escrava das paixões.
Agora, Hume não está
dizendo exatamente
o que a Oprah afirma aqui.
Sobre isso, vamos ter a oportunidade de
falar mais durante as seções.
Mas, novamente, ao ver a história de
Leôncio, a história de Medeia,
a história de escolher o time
vencedor nas apostas de basquete
e aqui, com a Oprah, fica a ideia
de que a alma tem partes,
que existem conflitos dentro nós.
Então, o que eu quero fazer nesta aula
é percorrer com vocês as 5
leituras atribuídas para hoje:
3 obrigatórias e 2 complementares.
Cada uma tenta dar voz
por meio da identificação
de uma taxonomia
para a ideia de que algumas vezes
somos puxados numa direção
e outras vezes em outra.
O 1º tema, que eu vou
detalhar mais tarde na aula,
é a divisão de Platão entre
razão, espírito e apetite.
O 2º é a discussão de
Hume sobre a relação
entre razão e paixão.
E Jonathan Haidt, no livro que
lemos o 1º capítulo,
apresenta uma metáfora maravilhosa
para a compreensão da
relação entre a razão –
a parte de nós mesmos a que
temos acesso direto,
consciente, e sobre a qual temos
controle regulador direto –
e a outra massa de impulsos e
instintos que nos constitui,
que ele sugere que podemos
entender como um elefante
que tentamos controlar a partir de
quaisquer mecanismos possíveis.
A sugestão de Hume, na passagem lida,
é que o caminho e o impulso
para o movimento vem
– seguindo com a metáfora –
por meio da criatura cujos as
patas estão no chão.
Assim, embora seja verdade que há uma
espécie de direção possível
por parte do ginete,
o impulso para a ação vem dessas
nossas partes sobre as quais
não temos controle racional direto.
E essa ideia de que somos um
conjunto de unidades
que nos puxam em várias direções
está no cerne da incrivelmente
influente, embora altamente controversa,
imagem da mente humana que Sigmund Freud
apresentou na 1ª metade do século 20.
Portanto, a ideia de Freud é que cada
um de nós, quando nascemos,
somos um feixe de desejos,
necessidades e paixões incoerentes.
Temos um desejo de comer, temos um
desejo por certos tipos
de conforto, temos desejos
sexuais incrivelmente vivos.
E esses desejos não têm grau de
consistência entre eles.
Puxam-nos em todas as direções
e nos levam a agir de maneiras que
visam a sua satisfação.
A história do
desenvolvimento humano, diz
Freud,
é a história do desenvolvimento de 2
tipos de capacidades reguladoras.
A uma, a que ele chama de ego,
é uma parte do eu que é
sensível à realidade.
Ela reconhece que você não pode
querer, ao mesmo tempo,
matar o seu irmão e se
casar com o seu irmão,
porque se o seu irmão está morto,
você não pode se casar com ele.
Ela pode reconhecer, de fato,
que você não deseja matar o seu
irmão nem se casar com ele,
embora esse pedaço de informação pode
ser que venha de uma 3ªparte.
Assim, temos este pacote de paixões
que nos puxam em várias direções.
E à medida que nos desenvolvemos,
surge uma parte de nós mesmos
sensível à realidade.
E quando isso ocorre,
nos tornamos conscientes de
nossa experiência.
Assim, enquanto esses desejos nos
puxam em vários caminhos,
sem mesmo estarmos cientes
disso, o ego, o senso do eu,
é algo a que temos acesso reflexivo.
À medida que passamos a interagir
com outras pessoas no mundo,
obtemos informações sobre as
formas adequadas de regulação,
de se portar consonante as
normas da sociedade.
E à medida que interiorizamos isso
e fazemos com que seja parte do
que nós mesmos endossamos,
se torna o que Freud chama de superego,
por vezes considerado a consciência.
Então, o cenário aqui é que
existem todos os tipos
de partes inconscientes de nós
mesmos; algumas são unidades
que nos puxam para fazer coisas
como comer e procriar,
outras são os aspectos mais sensíveis
às limitações da realidade,
outras as normas da sociedade.
E, acima disso, numa parte muito
menor de nós mesmos,
está um aspecto do qual
somos conscientes.
Há detalhes da imagem freudiana
que foram desacreditadas por
todos os tipos de razões.
Mas a ideia básica de que temos
trações inconscientes
em direções rejeitadas por
nós, se tornou, penso eu,
parte de como é esta cultura
ocidental autoconcebida.
Eu acho quase impossível
subestimar o grau
em que a imagem freudiana fundamenta
a literatura do século 20,
o cinema do século 20 e a
autocompreensão do século 20.
A imagem freudiana, embora
tenha 3 partes,
não é exatamente a imagem platônica.
Apetite e id se correspondem,
mas o espírito não é a
mesma coisa que o ego;
e razão e superego estão mais
ou menos correlacionados.
Quem estiver intrigado com
essa discussão
pode voltar à leitura desta
semana e ver a apresentação
do próprio Freud sobre a teoria
que eu acabei de explicar.
A 4ª distinção que eu vou expor
na principal parte da aula
é uma extensão contemporânea entre
o sistema 1 e o sistema 2:
ou entre um tipo de sistema automático
de processamento heurístico
e um sistema racional de
processamento reflexivo.
E, como eu disse, eu vou falar sobre
isso na maior parte da aula.
Eu quero apresentar agora o nosso
5º conjunto de divisões.
E elas são as 4 divisões
que Jonathan Haidt
identifica no capítulo de abertura.
Então, como vocês sabem,
nós lemos Platão,
tínhamos a opção de ler
Hume e ler Freud,
lemos o fragmento de
Evans e lemos Haidt.
A 1ª distinção de Haidt é entre o
que ele chama de mente e corpo.
Ele explica que, embora grande parte
da nossa regulação corporal
ocorra pelo cérebro, existem locais
independentes de processamento.
O intestino – os órgãos
digestivos –, em especial,
pode funcionar de forma
relativamente independente do
cérebro,
e ele apresenta alguns exemplos.
Mas, surpreendentemente, uma das
coisas que ele não aborda
é o famoso exemplo de Mike, o frango
sem cabeça, que era um frango
– aqui está ele na capa da Life –
que logo após a Segunda Guerra
Mundial foi decapitado
e que viveu por mais 18 meses,
perfeitamente feliz.
Aqui está ele dançando.
E se vocês forem ao YouTube, verão
uma versão ao vivo de Mike,
o frango sem cabeça.
Aqueles que se comprometeram a
desligar a internet...
Agora eu estou arrependida.
Assim, o ponto sobre o Mike, o
frango sem cabeça,
é que há todo um conjunto de
representações de controle motor
que ocorrem, não no órgão onde
normalmente se espera, na cabeça,
e sim ao longo da medula
espinal, de várias maneiras.
A 1ª divisão aludida por Haidt
é que isso, na verdade,
é uma característica biológica nossa.
Essa regulação da ação ocorre
a partir de todos os tipos de
processos biológicos,
alguns dos quais
encontrados aqui em cima
e outros comunicados com as
partes dos nossos membros
e assim por diante, apenas
através das partes inferiores
da medula espinal.
A 2ª divisão de Haidt
ressalta a importância
da divisão entre os lados
esquerdo e direito do cérebro.
Como muitos sabem, temos algo chamado
corpo caloso ao longo da
metade da nossa cabeça,
que liga todas as coisas que ocorrem no
lado direito da nossa cabeça
com todas as coisas que ocorrem no
lado esquerdo da nossa cabeça.
Acontece que em certos tipos de
pacientes epilépticos
a única maneira de curar a epilepsia,
os ataques elétricos que
percorrem o cérebro,
é cortando o corpo caloso.
E fazendo isso, por uma necessidade
médica, a ciência descobriu
que o grau em que ocorre o
processamento nos 2 lados do cérebro
é relativamente independente.
Basicamente, tudo o que entra
pelo campo visual direito
é processado no hemisfério
esquerdo do cérebro
e tudo o que entra pelo
campo visual esquerdo
é processado no hemisfério
direito do cérebro.
E embora muitas
características do
cérebro
estejam duplicadas em todo o
hemisfério, outras estão
concentradas.
Por exemplo, nos cérebros
de pessoas destras,
a linguagem é uma atividade do
hemisfério esquerdo.
E dessa forma Haidt descreve
algumas pesquisas famosas
feitas nos anos 1950 pelo
neurocientista Michael Gazzaniga,
em que um paciente que
havia sido submetido
a um corte do corpo caloso é
apresentado a algumas imagens
que entram pelo campo visual
esquerdo e, consequentemente,
são processadas no lado
direito do cérebro;
ou imagens que entram pelo campo visual
direito e, consequentemente,
são processadas no lado
esquerdo do cérebro.
Interessante, pois as
informações processadas
no lado esquerdo do cérebro,
desculpe, no lado direito do cérebro
não estão
linguisticamente
disponíveis.
O centro de linguagem é o lado
esquerdo nas pessoas destras...
não estão
linguisticamente
disponíveis;
quando o sujeito olha para
algo que entra por aqui,
não há processamento
linguístico do que ele vê.
Mas quando pediram para ele
explicar o que estava
no seu campo visual, ele empreendeu
o que Gazzaniga chamou de
confabulação.
Então, são mostradas ao homem aqui,
para este lado do cérebro,
imagens de neve e ele é
convidado a escolher
– lembrem-se, este é o cérebro
direito, por isso é a mão esquerda –
o que combina com elas.
E ele seleciona com a mão esquerda,
controlada pelo hemisfério direito a
partir do campo visual esquerdo,
uma pá, algo extremamente
útil se há neve.
Enquanto isso, o lado esquerdo do
cérebro, por meio do olho direito,
controlando a mão direita,
vê uma pata de galinha
e seleciona uma galinha.
Portanto, um dos lados do cérebro
vê uma pata de galinha
e, escolhendo o que combina com
isso, seleciona a galinha.
O outro lado do cérebro vê a neve e,
escolhendo o que combina com
ela, seleciona a pá.
Até aqui tudo bem.
Eu já disse que o cérebro está
segregado nesses tipos de operações,
por isso não é de estranhar
que o lado direito
selecione algo que vai com o que ele viu
e o lado esquerdo selecione algo
que vai com o que ele viu.
O que acontece depois?
O que acontece é que o homem olha
para a pá e para a galinha,
as suas escolhas,
e é confrontado com a pergunta por
que ele escolheu essas coisas.
Agora, por mais longe que vá o
centro de linguagem do cérebro,
ele não tem a menor ideia de por que
escolheu a pata de galinha.
Certo? Essa informação não
entrou na parte do cérebro
dele onde está ocorrendo o
processamento linguístico.
No entanto, o que ele faz é
algo chamado confabular.
Ele diz: Oh! Eu peguei a pá
porque eu preciso da pá
para o galinheiro.
Ele aparece com uma explicação
de por que ele escolheu como escolheu.
Nos casos de hipnose, há uma
fenomenologia semelhante.
As pessoas se encontram
com os braços e as pernas de
um determinado jeito e,
imediatamente, chegam a uma
explicação confabulada
de por que estão fazendo o
que estão fazendo.
Somos as típicas pessoas que
leem o nosso comportamento
fora de nossas experiências.
E ao falar de emoção e
autocompreensão,
voltaremos a esse assunto.
Assim que o ponto sobre o cérebro
esquerdo e direito tem 2 lados.
O 1º é que se trata de um 2º
exemplo de suporte biológico
da ideia de que estamos
divididos de certas maneiras.
E o 2º é a ideia de
confabulação no sentido de
que,
para usar a metáfora do
ginete de elefante,
é como se o ginete pensasse que
são as suas patas no chão,
em vez das do elefante.
A 3ª divisão que Haidt descreve
é a divisão entre o que ele chama de
cérebro antigo e cérebro novo.
Basicamente, as partes do cérebro,
o tronco cerebral e as
regiões subcorticais,
que compartilhamos com os
animais não-humanos;
e as partes do cérebro que são
muito mais desenvolvidas
nos seres humanos, como a
região cortical e,
em particular, o córtex pré-frontal.
E Haidt conta uma história
que é útil para entender como
ocorre a autorregulação.
O meu palpite é que muitos já viram
alguma versão das famosas
imagens desta pessoa.
Alguém sabe o nome dele?
Sim?
Estudante: Phineas Gage.
Profª. Tamar Gendler: Phineas Gage.
Este é Phineas Gage,
um operário ferroviário do século 19
que estava preparando dinamites,
como parte de seu trabalho.
A dinamite explodiu e uma barra de
metal perfurou o cérebro dele.
Mas, como Mike, o frango sem cabeça,
Phineas Gage sobreviveu e,
não só não morreu, como
viveu por muitos anos.
Na cirurgia de reconstrução,
ficou claro que o dano causado
pela barra havia sido
numa área do cérebro chamada
córtex pré-frontal ventromedial.
Bem aqui é o córtex pré-frontal.
E o resultado do acidente que
aconteceu com Gage
foi o mesmo que aconteceu com a
professora da Universidade
da Virgínia, que Haidt
descreve em sua história.
Houve uma perda da capacidade de um
certo tipo de autorregulação.
Então, de certa forma como Medeia,
embora Gage fosse capaz de ver a
coisa normativamente correta
a fazer – ver o que ele deveria
fazer, entendê-la, explicá-la,
articulá-la, dizer o que seria
socialmente apropriado –,
ele se viu incapaz de agir como
sabia que deveria agir.
Seria como dizer a ele: você não deve
gritar num ambiente público
quando estiver chateado.
Ele entenderia que esse tipo de
comportamento é inadequado,
mas ainda assim seria
incapaz de controlá-lo.
Ele acabaria fazendo o que,
para Freud, foi o id que
disse para ele fazer ou,
para Platão, foi o apetite que
disse para ele fazer.
Uma e outra vez descobriu-se
em indivíduos com lesões no
córtex pré-frontal
que eles enfrentavam dificuldades
com a autorregulação.
Portanto, parece que ao menos um
dos lugares em que Platão
dizia que se assentava a razão
está nesta parte
específica do cérebro.
E, de fato, existe uma boa evidência
de que os indivíduos que
sofrem, por exemplo,
de transtorno do déficit de atenção
com hiperatividade, o TDAH,
apresentam uma função mais baixa
do córtex pré-frontal.
Então, quando Haidt fala
de cérebro antigo
– uma parte do cérebro que nós
compartilhamos com os seres
que agem por instinto – e cérebro
novo – córtex e, em particular,
as partes do córtex que estão
especialmente bem desenvolvidas
nos seres humanos, como o
córtex pré-frontal –,
uma das coisas que ele está falando
é dessa capacidade de autorregulação.
E quando falarmos de
fraqueza da vontade,
umas 5 aulas à frente,
falaremos sobre algumas das
maneiras de explorar
o fato de que nós temos estes
cérebros complexos capazes
de padrões de aprendizagem tanto
pelos sistemas antigos
quanto pelos novos.
Assim, somos capazes da regulação
do mesmo modo que os cães e gatos são.
Se você quer treinar a sua gata para
não subir no sofá dizendo:
"Por favor, não suba no sofá,
você vai deixar pelo e minha
tia é alérgica",
não será um modo eficaz de
convencê-la a não subir no sofá.
Para treinar a sua gata você
precisa fazer algo
como colocar um pedaço de
papel amassado no sofá,
causando um barulho desagradável
toda vez que ela senta.
Ou talvez borrifar um pouco de água
sempre que ela subir no sofá.
Ao fazer isso, você configura as
associações entre estar no sofá
e um resultado negativo,
modificando as associações
dela com o sofá.
Mas você não faz isso de um
jeito que estimula
a autorregulação reflexiva.
Nós, como seres humanos, com
cérebros antigos e novos,
podemos nos regular da mesma maneira
que regulamos e treinamos os animais,
associando certas atividades
com coisas positivas
e outras com coisas negativas.
Mas também podemos fazer isso
usando um tipo de reflexão
e autorregulação que envolve um
certo tipo de autocontrole.
E falaremos mais sobre isso
nas próximas aulas.
O que eu quero fazer agora, após ter
dado alguns textos literários
em que está presente a ideia da
divisão da alma e que,
em seguida, analisam rapidamente
as várias divisões que
lemos para hoje, é...
Oh, desculpem!
Existe um 4º exemplo de Jonathan Haidt.
O que eu quero fazer, na verdade,
é explicar sobre o
processamento controlado
e o automático e, depois, fazer o
que eu disse que iria fazer.
Então, alguns de vocês,
depois da aula,
saem da sala e vão andando,
talvez peguem o elevador,
até uma aula expositiva
ministrado por John Bargh
em outra parte da WLH.
Eu quero descrever um estudo
que John Bargh fez
há cerca de 15 anos,
que traz à tona a relação
entre o processamento
controlado e o automático.
Bargh chamou as pessoas ao laboratório
para participarem de algo intitulado
"tarefa de frases embaralhadas".
A tarefa de frases embaralhadas é
uma tarefa onde você recebe
uma lista de palavras,
digamos, 5 palavras:
ele, bonita, entrada,
relevante, quinta-feira.
E pedem que você coloque 4
delas numa frase.
Ao fazer isso, você é
forçado a se envolver
com os significados das palavras.
A única ideia da tarefa de
frases embaralhadas
é fazer você pensar sobre
várias palavras.
Portanto, as pessoas foram
apresentadas a um conjunto de
palavras
que continha grande variedade
ou a um conjunto em que uma
porção de palavras eram termos
tipicamente associados com os idosos.
Palavras como enrugado,
bingo e Flórida.
Os indivíduos que montaram as frases
que continham palavras associadas
com os idosos presumivelmente
criaram nas mentes deles a
ideia de uma pessoa idosa.
E então, a variável
dependente, VD, medida por Bargh
foi o tempo que as pessoas levaram,
quando elas saíram do estudo,
para caminhar até o elevador.
Os indivíduos que tinham se dedicado
à tarefa típica das frases
embaralhadas chegaram até o elevador.
Mas aqueles que receberam palavras
associadas com os idosos
foram muito lentamente.
De fato, os indivíduos que
encontraram a condição normal
demoraram pouco mais de 7 segundos
para chegar ao elevador,
enquanto os indivíduos que tinham
as palavras associadas com os idosos
levaram mais de 8,5 segundos.
Provavelmente isso não foi
porque eles estavam pensando
de modo consciente:
"Oh, eu tenho que ir para o
meu jogo de bingo".
Foi por causa de alguma imagem evocada
inconscientemente na mente, abaixo
do nível de consciência,
e isso acabou afetando o
comportamento deles.
Numa série de estudos realizados por
Bargh nos anos posteriores,
e que ele continua realizando até hoje,
ele encontrou esse mesmo
efeito várias vezes.
Por exemplo, a alguns
indivíduos foram entregues
termos que tinham a ver
com boas maneiras
e a outros termos que tinham
a ver com grosseria.
E a variável dependente, a coisa
que ele estava medindo,
era qual seria a probabilidade de
interromperem o experimentador
quando eles precisassem
obter informações.
Os que receberam as palavras
associadas às boas maneiras
esperaram quase 15 minutos;
quem tinha as palavras
associadas à grosseria
se levantaram imediatamente e
interromperam o experimentador.
Mais recentemente, no domínio da
cognição incorporada,
ele esteve voltado para coisas como:
o que ocorre se você segura uma
caneca de café quente ou frio
antes de avaliar um currículo;
e os indivíduos que, no elevador,
ajudaram o experimentador
("você poderia segurar a minha
caneca, por favor?")
segurando uma caneca quente,
em vez de uma caneca fria,
eram mais propensos a avaliar um
currículo de forma positiva.
Ou seja, uma sensação de
calor num domínio
traz consigo uma sensação
de calor em outro.
Então essa é a quarta divisão.
OK. O que eu quero fazer nos
últimos 10 minutos de aula
é falar sobre os 2 textos que
ainda não foram comentados.
Em 1º lugar,
a divisão de Platão em
razão, espírito e apetite;
e em 2º, o material sobre
duplo processamento.
Embora a próxima aula seja
explicitamente sobre duplo
processamento,
se não tivermos tempo para
todo o material,
começarei a próxima aula com isso.
Portanto, no material um tanto
lascivo de Platão...
e eu espero que vocês o tenham lido.
É ótimo e muito divertido.
Nele, Platão... aqui está uma
maravilhosa representação dele
por um filósofo chamado John
Holbo, que vive em Singapura.
Platão descreve as 3 rês
partes da alma humana.
A 1ª é o que ele chama de
razão, ou logos
– representada aqui pelas carruagens.
A 2ª, espírito, às vezes
traduzido como honra, ou thumos.
E a 3ª, o apetite, ou epithumos.
Platão oferece uma série de metáforas
pela qual podemos entendê-las.
Em A República,
numa passagem que leremos
para a semana que vem,
ele descreve a razão como um homem,
o espírito como um leão
e o apetite como uma besta
de várias cabeças.
E na passagem que lemos,
retirada do Fedro,
ele descreve a razão como um cocheiro,
o espírito como um cavalo
de boa raça, nobre,
bem articulado, com pescoço
largo e porte real.
A sua pelagem é branca e ele é
controlável por uma única palavra.
O apetite, pelo contrário,
na imagem platônica
é um grande amontoado de membros
com um pescoço curto de
touro, um nariz achatado,
pele escura, olhos vermelhos,
companheiro da indecência e das
grandes ostentações,
desgrenhado, surdo como um poste,
submisso apenas ao chicote
e ao aguilhão.
E Platão descreve no
fragmento que lemos
um evento bastante emocionante,
onde um homem de Atenas se
apaixonou por um garoto
e o cavalo marrom dentro
dele, os apetites,
está pronto para executar essas
atividades que se enquadravam
na categoria de coisas que
Freud comentou no id.
E eu não estou querendo dizer que ele
queria almoçar com o garoto.
Assim que que o espírito
está atraído,
mas reconhece que existem
normas sociais,
e o cocheiro está envolvido na
tentativa de mantê-las na linha.
Platão escreve sobre o
processo em que o cocheiro
tenta colocar o cavalo escuro na linha,
enquanto o cavalo
basicamente tenta fazer
com que o homem se entregue
ao jovem amante.
Ele diz: "O tempo prometido chega,
os cavalos fingem que esqueceram do que
lhes foi dito pelo cocheiro.
Ele os lembrará.
O cavalo se debate.
Ele relincha.
Ele os puxa para frente.
Ele obriga que se aproximem
do garoto novamente,
com a mesma proposta; e assim
que estiverem perto,
ele solta a sua cabeça, endireita a
sua cauda, morde as rédeas
e galopa em direção ao jovem,
sem nenhuma vergonha."
O cocheiro
– ou seja, a razão, a autorregulação, o
superego, o córtex pré-frontal –
é golpeado com os mesmos
sentimentos de antes,
sentindo que esta não era a atividade
em que ele queria se envolver.
"É pior, ele está recaindo como se
estivesse na linha de partida.
Ele puxa as rédeas furiosamente para
controlar o cavalo insolente,
mais difícil desta vez, fazendo sangrar a
sua língua e mandíbulas sujas,
ajusta as suas pernas e ancas
firmemente no chão
e faz com que ele pare."
Agora essa ideia de que um dos jeitos
para controlar nossas paixões
é treinando nós mesmos como
treinaríamos um animal selvagem,
a partir da criação de
associações negativas
com determinados tipos de
atividades, é, de fato, uma visão
fundamental sobre como ocorre a
autorregulação humana.
E com relação às paixões
verdadeiramente fortes,
os apetites sexuais em especial, uma
espécie de autorregulação
que envolve um antídoto
igualmente forte é crucial.
A imagem de Platão é que na
alma bem-ordenada, a razão
– o cocheiro – toma a decisão e o
espírito e o apetite são,
por um processo de autorregulação,
domesticados e treinados.
Então, o que A República, o livro
que vamos lendo trechos,
descreve é um processo em que a
parte racional de nós mesmos
pode vir a estar no controle de
nossos espíritos e apetites.
Platão conta a história utilizando
uma metáfora de controle,
comparando a estrutura da alma humano
com a estrutura de uma cidade.
E ele diz que, assim como na
alma humana há a razão,
há o espírito e há o apetite,
também, numa cidade bem estruturada,
existem os guardiões, aqueles
regidos pela razão;
os auxiliares, basicamente soldados,
aqueles governados pela honra;
e uma espécie de trabalhador, que
é regido pelo apetite.
E indo e vindo entre
indivíduo e sociedade,
Platão descreve uma série de processos
por meio da qual as vontades,
desejos e impulsos
dos auxiliares e
trabalhadores, por um lado,
e o espírito e apetite, por outro,
podem ser colocados em harmonia
com o que dita a razão.
E acontece que,
descobriremos em 3 aulas,
esse tipo de harmonia é a
resposta oferecida
para a pergunta de Glauco
sobre por que é intrinsecamente
valioso agir de uma maneira moral.
Portanto, isso conclui a apresentação
da alma tripartida de Platão.
Na próxima aula,
falaremos sobre a discussão dos
modelos do duplo processamento
no contexto de 2 artigos que
leremos para a aula seguinte.
O 1º, como vocês devem
saber, ou devem ter visto,
é o discurso de Daniel
Kahneman no prêmio Nobel;
e vocês podem escolher entre
escutar o discurso
ou ler um artigo um pouco mais detalhado
que descreve o seu conteúdo.
E o 2º é um artigo que eu
escrevi sobre uma noção
que eu chamo de "alief",
que tenta reunir algumas das
ideias apresentadas hoje.
Então, espero vê-los
novamente na quinta-feira.